the vice president firing back at
critics who say she should have been
visiting the border by now this from
guatemala city yesterday afternoon
i came here to be here on the ground to
speak with the leader of this nation
around what we can do in a way that is
significant is tangible
and has real results and i will continue
to be focused
on that kind of work as opposed to grand
gestures so ardell quartzo now vice
president national border patrol council
art how you doing welcome back
is it a grand gesture is that how you
see it along the border look
look she can go down there and say that
she's trying to fix things over there
but unless you've been on the actual us
border
and seen what is affecting the agents
and what is affecting our nation's
security
how can you go over there and speak
unless she has a plan or an idea how to
resolve it
well she has to have seen what the issue
is and then she came back and she did
speak to those individuals down there
and said don't come to america
well you can that's nothing more than a
poker bluff
unless you're willing to change the
policies here or or reenact some of the
policies that worked
through the previous administration
individuals keep coming here
and they don't care about what
individuals what she would say
unless you change the policies unless
there's true consequences for
for committing that crime people are
going to continue to commit the crime
yeah art a few things here had had you
heard that there were 75 countries that
had crossed the border
have you heard that number before that
that gentleman just said with griff
jenkins
i hadn't heard the number but it's not
surprising at all because we do see
individuals from all over
the the world that actually are trying
to come in it's not just central
americans
another number that sticks out is they
were saying the numbers for the month of
may
there were there were over 170 thousand
apprehensions nationwide for the month
of may but what a lot of people will
continue not to talk about is the close
to fifty thousand got aways
and when you're hearing uh people that
are coming to the united states from
all over the world and then you hear
there's close to 50 000 godaways
it has to be worrisome because you don't
know who those people are
what countries they're coming from and
obviously you don't know their
intentions well that's 225 000 and one
answer you're talking about there of the
170 or 175
000 how many would have been returned to
their country
i'd have to look at the numbers but
realistically when they're coming and
they're
they're claiming uh you know uh asylum
and we don't have enough asylum judges
and we don't have enough
officers down there that are actually
fast tracking these cases
the majority of them are just going to
be allowed to remain in the united
states
and they'll never show up to their court
date they show up to their initial court
dates many times
but then when they're told they're not
going to remain here that they don't
have enough to stay here
then they go try to get their affairs in
orders and then they never show up again
well so
based on that math you're on target for
000 a month at the low end
is that right at the that's correct and
that's at the low end
and that's very important that you say
that at the low end
because those that get away there is no
actual number
it's it's pretty much you know the
number that they get from thin air okay
one last thing art yesterday the
president of guatemala was on camera
talking about
um how the coyotes
once they saw the change in policy with
the new administration
that the coyotes came to guatemala city
and started rounding up children and
getting them
to head north had you heard that before
i've seen it when i've spoken to the
individuals that are coming across
illegally with some of the children
they themselves have said and you know
this is from first-hand experience i had
one
child that told me i'm coming here
because your president said i could come
here and there's nothing you can do
about it
art del cueto thank you for coming back
and we will be in contact with you
thank you sir